[Música]
um dia me disseram há um que as nuvens
não é de algodão
sem querer eles me deram as chaves pra
sair dessa prisão
uma professora muito especial
ela passou essa música como uma tarefa
pra gente essa música chama sons quem
podemos sim dos engenheiros do hawaii em
composição de humberto que é assim
e aquela música ela marcou muito a minha
vida
à medida que eu ia ouvindo interpretando
aquela letra tudo ia ficando mais claro
cantando o intervalo na minha escuridão
de hoop em mim uma estrela de brilho
raro eu vou contar pra vocês
a história de um garoto persistente uma
história que começa com todas as
probabilidades de possibilidades
possíveis para dar errado
meu pai ele era um trabalhador rural sem
terra
infelizmente acabou morrendo acampamento
sem terra
minha mãe uma mulher de pouco estudo
ela teve que aprender a lavar roupa para
cuidar dos seus seis de seus três filhos
e um belo dia nós morávamos em um
barracão x barracão pegou fogo e nós
tivemos que mudar para um cortiço
nesse cortiço moravam mais quatro
famílias da minha casa no meu barracão
nesse cortizo nós não tínhamos televisão
nós não tínhamos geladeira e de se
curtir só tinha um banheiro e esse
banheiro era compartilhada por todo o
mundo
um belo dia
e um preço dia belo porque eu aprendi
uma lição triste porque já nós já
estávamos há quase dois dias sem ter o
que comer em casa
belo porque eu aprendi eu aprendi que eu
podia fazer algo para mudar a realidade
nós já estávamos há quase dois dias sem
ter o que comer
eu tive que não avizinha pedi a ela uma
corzinha de arroz pra gente poder fazer
aquela cozinhada foi foi a única
refeição que nós tivemos
depois de quase dois dias sem ter o que
comer eu sentado olhando do olhar da
minha mãe
o olhar da minha mãe dizia pra mim ela
não tinha coragem de falar porque minha
mãe como era lavadeira ela desenvolveu
um problema chama bico de papagaio
ela teve que parar ela não estava lavar
roupa e aí por causa disso ela não tem
dinheiro para comprar as coisas pra
gente comer e aquele olhar da minha mãe
vinha carregado de emoções e ele falava
comigo que eu tinha que fazer algo para
mudar a nossa realidade esse côrtes que
eu morava que ele era um cara bairro de
classe média alta
meus vezes eles a maioria tinha um carro
e aí veio o meu primeiro
empreendedorismo em casa minha mãe
lavava roupa então tinha um balde tinha
sabão tinha pan e tem escova todo sábado
eu saí de manhãzinha ia de casa em casa
batendo na porta pedindo pra me lavar um
carro as pessoas às vezes deixava lavar
o carro
eu voltava pra casa feliz e satisfeita
aquele momento pra mim é um momento de
de ecstasy no meu coração porque eu
estava fazendo
mesmo ainda criança estava fazendo algo
para mudar nossa realidade
eu tinha um tio que ele era produtor
rural ele produzir abacaxi e ele vendeu
trabalhando no chão para vendê-la
cachecol e na feira
nós todos sábado passado em casa batido
por tão escuro ele estava escuro e
agentes do mercado municipal
além de abacaxi eu chegava no mercado e
assim que eu chegava no mercado eu já
queria a gente ficava em cima do
caminhão eu queria tomar um café
eu te olhavam para mim e falava o osso
cabanos de chegar já que a tomar café eu
inventava todas as desculpas possíveis
mas lá no fundo é por que aquela era a
melhor refeição que tinha na semana
meu paladar chega de salivar lembro-o
todos os detalhes
era um pão de 12 que eu te levava com
uma mortadela e um cafezinho recém 4
eu comi aquela refeição com um todo o
prazer do mundo ficava o dia todo
mercado debaixo do sol vem tendo abacaxi
à tardinha meu tio me pagava pra quem
não conhece a tarde no mercado é o
melhor momento de fazer as compras têm a
xepa a xepa é onde veio o sacolão do
tudo junto e misturado
eu fazia as minhas compras eu embora pra
casa à tarde com uma sacola com tudo
junto e 80 aquela sacola às vezes a
banda estourava e escorregando mas eu ia
feliz e satisfeito
eu estava indo com dinheiro no bolso eu
estava em verduras frutas que a gente
passava toda a semana em casa
em 2002 eu estava na escola pública e o
reitor de uma faculdade chegou lá na
faculdade ele chegou a fazer a
apresentação do vestibular
a lei será o que é isso mesmo singular
houve estava formando e ele pediu que
todos os carros de perto de cair de pé e
passam a dinâmica para a gente mudar de
lugar
a escola tinha preparado melhor cadeira
pra ele eu morro que avançou com licença
e na cadeira dele cadeira chiquilín da
pomposa o reitor da universidade
ele olhou riu bastante depois ele
explicou pra gente que o objetivo da
nossa aquela dinâmica é que a gente
saísse da nossa zona de conforto sair do
lugar que a gente estava a sair daquela
cadeira e buscasse uma melhora aquela
mensagem
estudei com muito afinco naquele ano eu
passei em terceiro lugar no curso de
letras inglês não vê universidade
estadual a vida da gente é feito de
detalhes e um detalhe
eu não sabia inglês e eu fui fazer uma
faculdade de letras de 3
então eu tive que estudar baixos do que
os meus colegas porque os meus colegas
de conforto saber a língua eu não sabia
inglês não sabia bem o que estava
fazendo ali direito daquela faculdade
durante a faculdade eu trabalhei por
seis meses como vigia noturno ajudar a
custear as minhas despesas da costilha
em casa tirando katyn
o cat é um documento que habilita o zé
da aula de áudio zona rural
mas o maior o melhor emprego que eu tive
mais importante durante a faculdade foi
de mototáxi
por isso que deixa aquela mensagem faça
sempre o melhor
eu trabalhava de mototáxi e eu era o
mototáxi de confiança das pessoas
eu ia com o meu voto a criar até a casa
das minhas professoras deixava minha
moto lá pegava o carro delas levava os
filhos delas no balé do inglês da facom
na escola e voltava pegava minha moto ia
fazer um serviço e elas me pagavam por
aqui ele me pagava com muito prazer
nós precisamos pessoas de confiança e
esse prêmio de mototáxi lá na frente ele
fez toda a diferença na minha vida
porque em 2005
em 2005 eu não só foi aprovado no curso
de letras inglês
o detalhes nos colegas eles fizeram uma
aposta que eu só fui saber em 2005
eles apostavam que eu não passava do
primeiro ano da faculdade não sabe
inglês em 2005 graças a deus eu não só
passar na faculdade como eu passei em
terceiro lugar no curso técnico de
segurança pública da polícia militar
o ctsp só tinham 40 vagas eu vou fazer o
meu curso de tesser diamantina
mas lembro que eu falei com certeza a
vida da gente é feita de detalhes
o curso quem já foi aprovado em um
concurso sabe é um ano
o curso e você tem que ter uma reserva
financeira para você custear todas
aquelas etapas e eu não tinha essa
reserva financeira
eu não tinha e aquelas professoras que
conhece a minha história
sabiam da minha persistência da minha
garra da minha luta elas fizeram uma
vaquinha e me ajudava ostia as minhas
passagens para fazer o curso o
psicotécnico que é na capital que não
era aqui mas em 2009 já estava
confortável já que estava de novo na
zona de conforto da minha vida foi
quando a vida me pegou de novo jogou na
parede eu passei pelo que eu considero o
pior momento da minha vida
pior do que a fome pior do que a miséria
é pior do que o incêndio que eu vi todas
as coisas da minha casa pegando fogo
eu comecei a dar febre dar condições e é
internado por mais de 40 dias no
hospital quando tinha 40 dias que estava
no hospital galfi ano eles descobriram
nódulos no pulmão e já me levaram direto
à sala de cirurgia os médicos retiraram
mais de 50% do meu pulmão
eu fiquei tanto tempo no hospital eu
comecei a entender todos os sons como eu
não podia levantar da cama eu escutava
os sons de dois sons que marcou muito a
minha vida no hospital
um dos sons é o som da rodinha que traz
a comida do hospital
aquele cheiro e estava uma repulsa já
tinha 40 dias comendo a comida do
hospital
existe um outro som que marcou mais a
minha alma é o som do carrinho que
levava o cadáver
eu não sou muito triste
[Música]
lá dentro de mim eu imaginava que aquela
pessoa não podia fazer nada mas pelo
melhor ali finalizavam a vida daquela
pessoa e aquilo pra mim doía muito
em conseqüência desse problema de saúde
perdi o futebol com a parte do pulmão eu
tive síndrome do jaleco branco teve
pertençam
tive obesidade desenvolvi o pior de
todos os problemas que como eu diz até
hoje já enfrentei na minha vida que foi
a depressão a depressão pra mim ela é
muito pior que a miséria
ela é muito pior do que a fome pois é
uma doença que você não tem feridas
a pessoa que está com depressão ela tem
vergonha de contar que ela está passando
por aquilo
na fase mais aguda da minha depressão eu
tinha medo de estar em contato com a
corda porque eu achava que eu ia rolar
aquela corda no meu pescoço e acabar com
a própria vida
eu era policial militar que tinha medo
de encostar na minha arma porque eu
tinha medo de pegar aquela arma e fazer
um atentado contra minha vida
a depressão você não sabe qual time você
está jogando
são filas que dói mas você não acha
essas feridas
o ponto mais crítico da minha depressão
afirma o psiquiatra
ele receitou três remédios
ele receitou um remédio para dormir um
remédio pra acordar um remédio pra ficar
feliz mas dentro de mim eu escolhi o
quarto remédio eu escolhi sei feliz
foi quando eu entrei no esporte eu
comecei a pedalar com meu cunhado meu
cunhado
ele acreditou em mim ele acreditou que
era capaz de subir aquela montanha com
ele quando nem eu mesmo acreditava mas
se ele acreditava em mim
eu não podia decepcionar eu ia subir
aquela montanha
nem que fosse empurrando aquela
bicicleta
o sport foi a chave da saída da minha
depressão através do esporte
eu pude conhecer quais são as minhas
falhas
todos nós temos falhas todos nós temos
fraquezas o lap dei as minhas fraquezas
e conseguir fortalecer nas minhas
fraquezas mas através do esporte
eu consegui o que eu acho que é mais
importante é descobrir quais eram os
meus pontos fortes e através dos meus
pontos fortes e fortaleza ce e ainda
mais do que eu já era forte
afinal de contas a vida já tinha dado
tudo de ruim e eu peguei tudo aquilo
batido no liquidificador transformei uma
pessoa melhor
hoje eu sou pai de uma linda família
sou professor estou policial militar há
14 anos trabalha com mais de 28 mil
jovens
sou vice campeão brasileiro de duathlon
do atual competição onde você corre
pedala e corre
sou homem para homem e você nada 1.900
metros você pedala 90 metros e você
corre 21 quilômetros para o próximo ano
eu estou classificado eu sou um atleta
ranqueado pela é com a federação
brasileira de triathlon para o próximo
ano
eu estou classificado para o mundial de
doha tão na espanha para o mundial de
triathlon do canadá
somos uma pessoa
nós somos uma pessoa e sete bilhões de
pessoas
todos nós não são os únicos mas o que
você tem feito
se você não existisse a partir de hoje o
mundo todo e assim falta de você você
está escrevendo a história da sua vida
sua vida é única
dá tempo de você colocar coisas
incríveis na sua vida e é por isso que
aquela música de humberto gessinger do
engenheiros do hawaii aquela má da
professora uma professora tão especial
marcou tanto a minha vida porque afinal
de contas somos quem podemos ser sonhos
que podemos ter
muito obrigado gol
ligado à a deus